Speaker 1: Well, there are seven dead in another
mass shooting, this one in California. Now,
what's confusing and I admit it is confusing, this
is not the mass shooting from a few days ago. This
is a different California mass shooting. And BBC
News has a brief article about it. Half Moon Bay,
seven dead in another California mass shooting.
The U.S. state of California is reeling from its
third mass shooting in eight days after a man
shot dead seven former coworkers south of San
Francisco. This was in Half Moon Bay. Some of
the victims were Chinese American. The suspect,
Chun Lee Zhao, 66 years old, was arrested
after driving to a police station. This is,
remember, separate from the death of 11 people in
Monterey Park, which is 6 hours southeast of Half
Moon Bay. And just over a week ago, six people,
including a teenage mother and baby, were killed
at a property in Goshen in central California.
Now, there have been 40 mass shootings in the
United States this year so far. Let let me make
sure I'm being clear about that. Mass shootings,
if you want to know how many shootings
have there been? It's hundreds. Hundreds,
hundreds. But if we limit it to mass shootings,
there have been 40 this year. And it is,
of course, the 25th of January. So more than one
per day. You can find information about them on
the Gun violence archive. They have a category
called mass shootings. They also have a separate
category for all shootings, which you can find.
And you will see the shooting I just mentioned
listed Half Moon Bay. Since this incident
yesterday, there were two more mass shootings,
including not including the two. Those two
shootings were in Oakland, California. One killed,
four injured. And in Red Springs, North Carolina,
three killed and one injured. Also listed here
from a few days ago is the Monterey Park shooting.
12 dead, nine injured. We're out of ideas, guys.
We don't know how to prevent this. Of course,
this is the only country where this happens
with this regularity, but we have absolutely no
idea how to prevent it. We're all out of ideas,
even though we haven't really tried anything
yet. And I think this is as good a time as any
to remind everyone's memory refresh everyone's
memory of the list I provided. Who knows after
which mass shooting. Maybe this was after a Texas
mass shooting a year ago. It's constant. So I
don't know. When I last showed you this list, it's
probably been about a year. We have things that we
can do. And what I would immediately do if things
were up to me and again, remember, this is all
without displacing the Second Amendment. We have
a Second Amendment. None of my suggestions here
say get rid of the Second Amendment. But here are
things we could immediately do. And the gun show
loophole, which refers to the fact that federal
law doesn't require unlicensed private sellers to
do a background check. If you just privately sell
a gun and someone shows up to get it, you are not
required as an unlicensed private seller to have
a background check done on that individual. That's
a horrifying loophole. We should have universal
background checks, which would require just about
every firearms transaction to go through the
next National Instant Criminal Background check
system. And that would close what is sometimes
called the private sale exemption. Universal
background checks are not required by federal law.
There are 22 states in D.C. which do require them,
at least for some private sales, but is not nearly
universal. There should be a mandatory waiting
period from when you purchase the gun to when
you actually get the gun. There should be no high
capacity weapons sold to anybody under age 25.
You should be required to have got insurance and
it should be significantly more expensive without
a parent. If you were under 25, if you're under
25 and you want a gun, you should be required to
get community support letters from adults in your
community that can say, I know this person and I
have no concerns about them having a firearm. Some
weapons should be banned. I mean, there are some
weapons that there have no recreational or other
value. Then as mass killing machines, they aren't
valuable as in terms of sport or hunting. I'm not
pretending I have the full list right now, but
there should be some weapons banned. You should
be required to have a periodic mental health
evaluation and the licensing process itself. To
even get the license to get the gun in the first
place should be significantly more extensive.
There should be a written and practical test,
like for a driver's license. There should be a
training and licensing period that isn't just one
weekend. It should be longer, like with vehicles.
And we should also have a gun buyback program,
give people an off ramp that feels better. Then
we're going to be confiscating guns. Now, I know
every time I present. This list. Someone writes
and says, David, that wouldn't have stopped this
specific shooter or that specific shooter. Well,
but it might stop the next one and it would have
stopped some of them. If we think of each shooting
that has taken place in almost every case,
some of these items would have been relevant,
some of these items, not all. And it would still
be a worthy cause to reduce the number of mass
shootings. It's January 5th and we've had 40 mass
shootings in the United States. So that is a list
that every time I look at it continues to make a
lot of sense. Some of these items there actually
is significant national support for some of them.
There is not necessarily, but we have things we
can try. And so far, the things that have been
done other than that period when there was an
assault weapons ban in the nineties and there was
a reduction in mass shootings during that period
of time, nothing else seems to. Prayers aren't
helping. Fixing doors isn't helping. Triple pane
windows are not helping, right? I mean, the things
that the right talks about aren't helping. And
then lastly, the right says, oh, mental health.
They also don't want to fund making the mental
health support system in this country more robust.
So they're also hypocrites as far as that goes